i would imagine you everyone must have
kissed your ass not only because you
were famous
from a famous family the beauty
you're very generous but you know what
i'm talking it wasn't like that at all
it doesn't matter what you look like or
anything like that
if when you were young you were made to
feel
not good enough if you were made to feel
not pretty not smart
if you were made to feel fat if you were
made to feel
unlovable then no matter what the
objective reality is you're going to
grow up feeling that that's true
did you look in the mirror and see an
ugly girl yeah
for sure you did and you know most
people will not believe you
and you know who else didn't marilyn
monroe yeah
where did you meet up with her actor's
studio and did you recognize another
person
just like yourself a great beauty she
recognized it in me
she was extremely insecure way more than
me
she didn't have my resilience
unfortunately
she was very beautiful i mean i know who
she was she was
very very famous i mean she would sit
next to me
and she would be shaking a little bit
she was so
nervous that she never did do a scene in
the class
she never did she was too scared you
know and i was just fascinated by the
dichotomy between who she was
and her beauty you know it's the today's
the day they're going to find out i'm a
fraud
syndrome and she felt a kinship with you
she
formed a friendship with you at that
point i think she was always attracted
to
vulnerability she she was a young kid
she would leave a party to go talk to
young children for example
and she oftentimes if we were in the
same
situation she would come to me to talk
and there was one party at least
frostburg's and she came late
and when she walked in i noticed that
there were men that started to like
hyperventilate
and kind of shake she walked straight to
me
and started talking to me and and i knew
it was because she was
she felt a kinship and she felt safe
with me
and i was very touched by that so anyway
all of that to say
that the objective reality isn't what
matters
it's it's how you were made to feel
about yourself when you were
very young and most of us are born with
those kind of or go through childhood
and we receive those kind of scars those
wounds
that ten that can stay with you unless
you very deliberately and intentionally
work to heal them